ja und ein weiteres video das sorgt
momentan für furore unter anderem wurde
ist bereits von den klitschkos gerät
bietet es ist von arnold schwarzenegger
der hollywood-star wendet sich darin an
alle russen und explizit auch an die
russischen soldaten in der ukraine und
er bittet sie die propaganda lügen des
kreml nicht weiter zu glauben hallo
hallo zusammen und danke dass ihr euch
die zeit nimmt mir zuzuhören
ich sende diese nachricht über viele
verschiedene kanäle waschen damit alle
meine lieben russischen freunde zu hören
und auch die russischen soldaten in der
ukraine
meine lieben russischen freunde es
passieren dinge in der welt von denen
ihr wissen müsst dinge von denen euch
nichts erzählt wird grausam mittelmeer
als langjähriger freund gibt es
russischen volk hoffe ich dass ihr hört
was ich zu sagen habe
ich erinnere mich daran dass ich mit
demselben herzlichen anliegen sprechen
damals zu den amerikanern nach dem 6
januar als dort eine aufbruch stand fand
und eine wilde meute versuchte das
kapitol zu stürmen und unsere regierung
zu stören
dass wir einfach unsere stimmen erheben
müssen und das gleiche passiert gerade
mit eurer regierung sie erzählt euch das
in diesem krieg entnazifiziert wird in
der ukraine aber das stimmt nicht denn
da zitiert wird überhaupt nicht denn die
ukraine ist kein nazi landes ist ein
land mit einem jüdischen präsidenten
ein präsident dessen drei onkel von
nazis umgebracht wurden
die ukraine hat diesen krieg nicht
begonnen
nicht nur nazis nicht nationalisten nein
der kreml hat diesen krieg begonnen
sonst keiner und das ist auch kein
kriegen des russischen volkes nein ist
dann kreml
sag es euch wie es ist 141 nationen der
un haben russland den aggressor genannte
nur vier nationen haben sich dagegen
ausgesprochen
die russischen truppen sofort und
abgewaschen und
die welt hat sich gegen russland
gestellt wegen russlands aktion war ein
sehr ukraine hat gebäudekomplexe werden
gesprengt raketen und bomben schlagen
ein auf kinderkrankenhäuser sogar auf
eine geburtsklinik
millionen von ukraine fliehen
viele frauen viele kinder viele ältere
menschen sie fliehen aus ihrem eigenen
land sie versuchen jetzt gerade
herausgekommen ist eine humanitäre krise
russland ist international isoliert
wegen der extremen brutalität diesem
moment
und die wahrheit ist auch dass die
folgen dieses krieges für russland
selbst furchtbar sein werden es tut mir
leid euch das zu sagen aber tausende
russische soldaten sind bereits
umgekommen
sie sind ein gefangen zwischen ukrainern
die für ihr heimatland kämpfen und der
russischen führung die für r oberhand
viele teile russischer ausrüstung wurden
zerstört oder zurückgelassen
und der wahl regnen autobomben auf
unschuldige zivile die schärfsten
globalen wirtschaftssanktionen aller
zeiten wurden gegen euer land verhängt
und auf beiden seiten des krieges leiden
ja jetzt doch diejenigen die es nicht
verdient habe
nicht nur ihr wurde belogen sondern auch
die russischen soldaten ihn oder gesagt
und kämpfen gegen nazi
das ukrainische volk wie helden begrüßen
oder ohne dass das ganze nur eine übung
sie wussten noch nicht einmal dass ein
krieg überhaupt stattfindet
ihm wurde auch gesagt dass sie die
russischen minderheiten in der ukraine
schützen sollen aber nichts davon ist
wahr nicht
dass die ukraine sich erbittert gewehrt
haben dass ihre familien beschissen und
irland wenn ich die babys dort aus
ruinen gezogen werden dann denke ich ich
schaue eine dokumentation über den
furchtbaren zweiten weltkrieg und nicht
die aktuelle nachrichtenlage
deswegen fordere ich das russische volk
auf die propaganda und die lügen zu
erkennen erzählt euren freunden
entfernt die desinformation
helft mir dabei die wahrheit zu
verkünden
berichtet euren landsleuten von der
humanitären katastrophe die in der
ukraine jetzt gerade passiert
und so präsident putin sage ich eines
ganz klar sie haben diesen krieg
begonnen sie führen diesen krieg sie
können diesen krieg beenden you started
this what you're winning des
jugendamtes vor